these pains you feel are messengers
listen to
them we carry inside us the Wonders we
seek outside
us only from the heart can you touch the
sky wherever you are and whatever you do
be in
[Music]
love the moment you accept what troubles
you've been given the door will
[Music]
open your heart knows the way run in
that
direction you are not a drop in the
ocean you are the entire ocean in a
drop as you start to walk on the way the
way
appears
silence gives
[Music]
answers whatever lifts the corners of
your mouth trust
[Music]
that my soul is from elsewhere I'm sure
of that and I
there yesterday I was clever so I wanted
to change the world today I am wise so I
am changing
myself be like a tree and let the Dead
Leaves
drop it's your road and yours alone
Others May walk it with you but no one
can walk it for
you in the blackest of your moments wait
with no
[Music]
fear maybe you are searching among the
the branches for what only appears in
The
Roots I'm not this hair I am not this
skin I am the soul that lives
within close your eyes fall in love stay
there what you seek is seeking
[Music]
you life is a balance of holding on and
letting
go raise your words not your voice it is
rain that grows flowers not
Thunder the soul has been given its own
ears to hear things the Mind does not
understand when you do things from your
soul you feel a river moving in you a
joy if all you can do is crawl start
[Music]
crawling patience is the key to
Joy if light is in your heart you will
find your way
home set your life on fire seek those
who Pan the flames
I know you're tired but come this is the
way respond to every call that excites
your
spirit you were born with wings why
crawl through
life patience with details makes perfect
a large work like the
universe
work keep digging your well water is
down there
[Music]
somewhere Love sometimes wants to do us
a great favor Hold Us upside down and
Shake all the nonsense
[Music]
out concentrate on the essence
concentrate on the
light death is not going away way the
sun sets the moon sets but they are not
[Music]
gone why do you stay in prison when the
door is wide
open ignore those who make you fearful
and sad that degrade you back towards
disease and
[Music]
death gamble everything for love if you
are a true human being have heartedness
does not reach into
Majesty conventional opinion is the ruin
of your
soul let go of your mind and then be
mindful close your ears and
listen the desire to know your own soul
will end all other
desires oh happy is the soul that sees
its own
faults when you lose all sense of self
the bonds of a thousand chains will
vanish everything about yesterday has
gone with yesterday today we need to say
new
[Music]
things love risks everything and asks
for nothing
whatever happens just keep smiling and
lose yourself in
love when we practice loving kindness
and compassion we are the first ones to
profit if you love someone you are
always joined with them in joy in
absence in solitude in strife
now I am sober and there's only the
hangover and the memory of
Love travel brings power and love back
into your
[Music]
life why should I be weary when every
cell of my body is bursting with
life when you feel a peaceful Joy that's
when you are near your
truth don't make yourself miserable with
what is to come or not to
come when setting out on a journey do
not seek advice from those who have
never left
[Music]
home I learned that every Mortal will
taste death but only some will taste
life
be kind and honest and harmful poisons
will turn sweet inside
[Music]
you if you want money more than anything
you'll be bought and sold your whole
[Music]
life friendship of the wise is good a
wise enemy is better than a foolish
friend if you are looking for a friend
who is faultless you will be
friendless be with those who help your
being the intelligent desire
self-control children desire
[Music]
candy I am a child whose teacher is love
surely my master won't let me grow to be
a fool
don't grieve anything you lose comes
back in another
form the wound is the place where the
light enters
[Music]
you one of the marvels of this world the
sight of a soul sitting in prison with
the key in his
hand don't get lost in your pain pain
know that one day your pain will become
your
cure be patient when you sit in the dark
the dawn is
coming suffering is a gift in its hidden
[Music]
Mercy greed makes man blind and foolish
and makes him une easy prey for
[Music]
death
prayer clears the mist and brings back
peace to the
[Music]
soul our greatest strength lies in the
gentleness and tenderness of our
heart the fault is in the one who blames
Spirit sees nothing to
criticize that which is false troubles
the heart but truth brings joyous
tranquility
[Music]
wear gratitude like a cloak and it will
feed every corner of your
life the only lasting beauty is the
beauty of the
heart repeat every day before going to
bed two words related to what you most
desire for example wealth and health
this way you will set a goal and not
forget about
it shine like the whole universe is
[Music]
yours if you wish to be a mine of jewels
open the deep ocean within your
heart truth lifts the Heart Like Water
refreshes the
soul silence is the language of God all
else is a poor
translation
stay in the spiritual fire let it cook
you all religions all this singing one
song peace be with
you I am in the House of Mercy and my
heart is a place of
[Music]
Prayer